yes that's right my list of the top 10
best movies in 2013 that is done hope
you guys enjoyed it now it's time for my
list of the top 10 worst movies of 2013
otherwise known as the fun list you know
this is more fun why make a list like
this because [ __ ] movies need love too
and if you're not gonna give them love
at least let them know that their [ __ ]
movies but hate to live in a world where
[ __ ] movies don't know their [ __ ] movies
hey that's why I'm here but first props
to you guys thank you for enjoying my
list of my top 10 favorite movies of
2013 I know it's easy to be like oh your
list sucks cuz that one movie I don't
agree with but generally speaking you
guys seem to be having fun with it and
that's cool this what these lists are
all about that being said let's dig
right into this because these [ __ ]
movies need to be talked about and
listed accordingly number 10 the first
one on my list the Smurfs - I'm actually
surprised it's not higher up on the list
I mean it is number 10 but I think to
myself yeah was dumbest [ __ ] but it was
made for kids and I remember well that's
right but it's making kids stupid so
what's my duty and responsibility to put
it on my top 10 list but the fact is
there are nine movies that are a lot
worse than this don't watch Smurfs dude
that would still be bad good night
coming in at number nine we got another
sequel Adam Sandler stop trying man
grown-ups - holy [ __ ] every head of a
Sandler movie I surprised myself cuz I
go into it I'm like maybe this won't be
like the last one maybe he's found his
wedding singer sparkup that's dead it
died even Rob Schneider wasn't in this
movie probably cuz he was like sorry man
I could do better
Rob Schneider said that Rob Schneider
said that God willing there's not a
grown-up's 3 don't do this to us again
number 2 eat the next poor attempt at
comedy that of course is gonna make my
list is scary movie 5 I grew up on fun
Leslie Nielsen spoof movies scary movies
men made holy [ __ ] they get worse and
worse and worse and they were really bad
not too long after the first one came
out it's moving like this that make me
go yeah [ __ ] I review movies online but
it's not as bad as it gets there is more
number 7 next one on this list die hard
ish that's what I call it I'm not gonna
call it die hard 5 I'm not gonna call it
a good day to die hard no it's die hard
ish she's not really die hard it was
Bruce Willis taking a nap the entire
time I was like sure I'll get a paycheck
what do I got to do not act like John
McClane easy and
it was a messy-ass plot it had no good
villain John McClane was nowhere in the
movie he had [ __ ] chemistry with his son
hearing about what the next die hard
movies about I should be more excited
about it this movie killed me on that
I'm like no it's gonna be terrible
shitty chemistry coppiced movies oh my
god when it's bad it's bad number six ah
another shitty chemistry come fish movie
men in black meets supernatural sounds
like you'd be easy to do you have a
winning combination right there just do
it it'll be fine then they made RIPD and
I was like parent Lee not I guess it's
men in black meets the best version of
Jonah Hex possible which is still really
shitty Jeff Bridges was talking like
white Bill Cosby the entire time Ryan
Reynolds was like God after Green
Lantern this better work sorry Ryan
please do something good soon otherwise
I'll give you a solid tip when you
deliver my Domino's Pizza number five
you know what else is really shitty a
really bad conspiracy spy movie paranoia
it happened I feel like paranoia was the
most generic movie I'm gonna talk about
on this list I could see the pitch
meeting is like spies and and stuff
Chris Hemsworth brothers in it I need
like that okay let's get this made
that's the thing I learned from this
just like Bruce Willis and diehard ish
Harrison Ford's like I don't have the
motivation dude my face is in the movie
and that's what you get that limb is not
Chris it's just not he runs really
masculine now number four I am really
over the teen romance [ __ ] seriously
the host can [ __ ] die it was invasion
of the Body Snatchers jumping on that
whole tween bandwagon [ __ ] this
shitty movies based off of a shitty book
written by the shitty author who wrote
the shitty Twilight books it's Twilight
with aliens that's odd what else is
there to say and I've been talking about
that for the sake of my sanity I'm done
down to the last three
you know these ones hit me to my core
and it was sad number three number three
Texas Chainsaw 3d I'm pretty sure this
was the first movie I reviewed of 2013
man it set a tone didn't it oh my god
Texas Chainsaw 3d had the balls to be
like you know what we're the official
sequel the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
everything else that came before it
doesn't matter the really attractive
people who can't act for [ __ ] who are in
this movie because they didn't
get the job and that one porn they
auditioned for their characters don't
make sense I feel like you could watch
this movie if you're trashed or hire
something with your friends even then
you'll still hate it but it's a thing to
do and again you can also give yourself
paper cuts in the webbing of your
fingers so whatever number two number
two is another comedy that sucked ass I
swear to god this is gonna be my number
one but it wasn't movie 43 is still
really bad though how fun is sketch
comedy it's awesome sketch comedy makes
YouTube thrive there is funny sketch
comedy everywhere on this website in the
movie theater nope not at all this movie
has big-name actors and that simply
means if you see anyone in this movie on
an infomercial telling you how you
should live your life don't listen to
them remember they were in movie 43 they
should not be giving you advice yeah I'm
talking to you Jesse Pinkman don't
listen to them you made better life
choices
no bo1 and here it is guys this is the
movie I'm sure a lot of you have been
thinking dude where's that movie did he
forget all about it no saving it for
number one after earth is my number one
I can never watch after Earth ever again
how on earth do you take Will Smith and
make him about as interesting as a
cheese wheel to be fair he's not the
main star of the movie he's already less
interesting son Jaden Smith is and I
understand the wanted to have this
father-son bonding project but my god
don't do that to us for the sake of you
having that after Earth was directed by
M night Shyamalan it was never marketed
as such everyone knew they were like
don't push on Ilan's name on there
people hate him now and it would movie
won't sell this is the movie after
airbender I was like maybe he's got one
more in him no I'm done sorry Shyamalan
I don't care to watch any of your sh I
was such a fan of yours back in sixth
sense the only way I will look forward
to a Shyamalan movie is if he changes
his name and I just don't know about it
this is one of those movies I tell my
friends I'm like dude I'm gonna sit you
down you're gonna watch this piece of
[ __ ] then I realize I'm like well that
means I'll have to watch it with them
and I just put the movie down I'm like
guess not I can never watch this movie
again ever if I do I am now gone insane
that or there's a gun to my head and I'm
duct-taped to a chair and my eyelids are
stapled open how [ __ ] boring doesn't
move you have to be and in the case that
is my list of the top 10 worst movies of
the year per my opinion so I want to
hear from you what are the worst movies
of the year to you what are the movies
were you like nope that shouldn't happen
whatever they are comment below
now I'd like to personally thank
everybody for a great 2013 this year was
pretty fun a few great movies a lot of
good movies and of course your fair
amount of dog sheds however you guys
have made it fun so I got nothing to
complain about and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more